we can all agree the choosing the right
career path at an early stage makes life
a whole lot easier
it lets you grow in terms of the
experience and in terms of the salary
that you can receive so here are the
best positions that you can put your
skills to good use i am rahul from
simply alone and these are the top 10
highest paying jobs of 2018 number 10 a
product manager is someone who plans to
achieve the long-term goals or aims of
the product they're also tasked with
coming up with imaginative and efficient
ways to achieve that goal now some of
the skills that are required for a
product manager are a strong
understanding of the concepts of PLM or
product lifecycle management knowledge
with the product management tools like
JIRA and asana strong analytical skills
and time management the average yearly
salary of a product manager is
approximately $100,000 some of the tools
that you might encounter as a product
manager of pivotal tracker axial and
poplar some of the responsibilities that
you would be taking up in this role are
delivering an operating plan which is
nothing but a plan to achieve the
strategic and tactical goals and
objectives to build a product portfolio
to manage and implement marketing
activities and to contribute towards
product strategy and mission which are
nothing but the steps you take for the
product and what you have planned for
the future number nine a full-stack
developer is someone who's familiar with
all the technologies that are required
to get an idea of the finished product
they're comfortable with all the layers
in computer software development now
where are the skills that you need to
become a full-stack developer knowledge
of the mean stack technologies which are
basically MongoDB X mysterious angularjs
and nodejs
API design and development coding and
stippling the fundamentals of web
development and database technologies
the approximate salary of a full stack
developer is 110 thousand US dollars now
some of the tools that might be used or
angularjs javascript no J's and MongoDB
the responsibilities that full stack
developer takes up are to design and
build restful api using mean stack
technologies to ensure that the
applications created are responsive and
keep with require standards to ensure
that the creator code has its integrity
intact and to implement data security
number eight a cloud architect is
responsible for overseeing a company's
cloud computing strategy like its cloud
adoption plans application design
management and monitoring but some of
the scarers that are required to become
a cloud architect are
good understanding of cloud application
architecture knowledge about the working
of AWS or a job to automate tasks of
functions and to coordinate them to
create a consolidated process and proper
communication skills the approximate
salary for cloud architect is 118
thousand US dollars some of the tools
that a cloud architect would be using at
Microsoft Azure the Google cloud
platform and AWS some of the
responsibilities of a cloud architect
would be to develop cloud architecture
which could be software as a service
platform as a service and so on to
develop a cloud strategy and coordinate
its adoption and to ensure application
architecture and deployments in the
cloud environment are done properly
number seven in AI architect Li it's
machine learning models with effective
features that can solve a client's
problem some of the skills that are
required in this role or sound knowledge
about mathematics and statistics
programming skills understanding our
tensorflow and similar technologies work
neural networks and having a clear
understanding of the technologies of
later to a like machine learning and
deep learning
now the approximate sorry for an AI
architect is 119 thousand US dollars
some of the technologies that an AI
architect might have to work with are
Python our torch and dense flow some of
the responsibility is that an AI
architect might have to take up our to
design and develop solutions that are
best suited for the clients developing
an appropriate strategy to deploy AI
techniques into businesses and to
develop complex AAA architectures number
six
DevOps engineer now this is a role
that's not been exactly defined it could
refer to anyone at the developer team
taking part in the deployment or network
operations for someone from the
operations team working on application
development that being said some of
these skills that a DevOps engineer
requires are coding and scripting
understanding deployment and network
operations being familiar with the
continuous integration and deployment
process of DevOps automating DevOps
tools like git and Jenkins to be an
expert in Linux or UNIX system
administration now the approximate
salary for a DevOps engineer is 123
thousand US dollars some of the tools
that a DevOps engineer might use our
puppet get darker and Jenkins some of
the responsibilities of a DevOps
engineer are to design and maintain the
continuous integral
and continuous deployment infrastructure
of Devon integrating cloud services so
that the processes can be automated and
shell scripting in PHP or Python and
Ruby number five it shouldn't be that
surprising that this role has gained so
much popularity considering the whole
deal with cryptocurrency in 2017
blockchain engineer creates and
implements digital solutions for
organizations by utilizing the concepts
of the blockchain technology they see
the organization's technical needs and
solve them using the applications that
they create now some of the skills that
a blockchain engineer would require odd
to understand the technologies behind
ripple are three ethereum and Bitcoin
understanding the consensus methodology
a deep understanding and how blockchain
exactly work and programming skills now
the approximate sorry for a blockchain
engineer is hundred and thirty thousand
US dollars some of the tools that a
blockchain engineer might use are
ethereum tyrion and M buck some of the
responsibilities of a blockchain
engineer are to understand the security
protocols tax crypto libraries and
functions and to develop and implement a
blockchain architecture number four a
software architect is an expert who
makes high-level design choices dictates
technical standards including software
coding standards tools and platforms
some of the skills that a Software
Architect requires our data modeling and
understanding of software architecture
good programming skills and strong
analytical skills now the approximate
salary of a software architect is 130
thousand US dollars some of the tools
that a software architect might use or
AutoCAD yes Katya Ito Max and Kaku
some of the responsibilities that a
software architect might have to take
apart to identify requirements of the
clients in a project and to perform
hands-on work to develop the prototypes
number three an IT solutions architect
understands IOT data management
practices they also deliver the data
that IOT enabled devices bring
inappropriately now some of the skills
of an IOT Solutions Architect our
understanding IOT solutions programming
skills in Java and Python understanding
the concepts of machine learning and
knowledge about hardware design and
architecture
now the approximate salary of a iot
Solutions Architect is 130 thousand US
dollars some of the tools that they
might encounter are you know kinoma and
flutter wireless some of the
responsibilities are to lead and
participate in activities of
architecture and design to help develop
an overall IOT ecosystem engagement
based on the IOT solutions framework and
an ability to translate business needs
into solution architecture requirements
number to placate architects are trained
to describe the structure and behave
big data solution and how that big data
solution can be delivered using big data
technology now some of the skills that a
big data architect must have to
understand the workings of Hadoop path
and know SQL data warehousing techniques
like AWS in oracle programming skills
and the ability to visualize data the
approximate salary of a big data
architect is hundred forty thousand US
dollars some of the tools that a big
data architect would use Apache spark 5
Java and Hadoop some of the
responsibilities of this role are to
manage the entire lifecycle of a Hadoop
a spark solution implementing the ETL
process which is made possible using the
tools that perform the extract transform
and load operation between one database
and the other working in a fast paced
and agile environment and to address big
data problems like dealing with
inaccurate information and a number one
the highest paid job role of 2018 is of
a data scientist now this shouldn't be
coming as much of a surprise considering
a data scientist a spot mathematician
part spotter friends and part computer
scientists they're experts who have
skills to solve complex technical
problems and the curiosity to find the
problems that need solving but the
skills required for this role are in
understanding of machine learning
algorithms scripting and programming
language it's knowing two coding
languages like Python or sass another
Nautica tools being able to identify
business issues and to provide an
appropriate solution now the approximate
salary for this role is 141 thousand US
dollars some of the tools that a data
scientist might use are Python our SAS
and SQL now the responsibilities of
someone in this role are to create
various machine learning based tools to
identify business issues and to provide
solutions and create data models to
create systems that can detect anomalies
automatically if you found yourself
lacking in the skills mentioned or you
just want to learn something new don't
worry we've got you back simply run
offers courses in project management
cloud computing networking big data
business intelligence tools in machine
learning blockchain programming DevOps
and data science we're here to help you
get certified and get ahead I hope you
guys found the video helpful and
informative
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here